the world cup of soccer is a
phenomenally huge event for the whole
world and this year no more so than in
Brazil Brazil though it is the home of
some of the world's best soccer players
and has won the World Cup several times
hasn't hosted the World Cup since 1950
when it lost heartbreakingly to Uruguay
and never lived that memory down well
there have been a lot of protests in
Brazil that have suggested that all of
the billions of dollars that Brazil is
spending on infrastructure and updating
its stadiums and security might be
better spent on things that would help
the Brazilian economy to grow at the
grassroots like health care and
education worker training housing and
those protests may yet continue during
the World Cup itself but there have been
a lot of dire predictions about how safe
people will be whether the Brazilian
World Cup will turn into something of a
disaster and an embarrassment
I don't think they're likely to turn out
to be true because we heard a lot of the
same predictions before the World Cup in
South Africa four years ago now the
World Cup in South Africa was viewed as
a big risk because here was a country
that had severe problems with crime and
there never had been a World Cup in
Africa before so the question was how
would the soccer officials and the local
officials deal with all of the potential
risks and things could go wrong in a
country like South Africa well it turned
out that those fears were broadly
exaggerated because it was a fantastic
festival of football that went off
without a hitch in fact there was
probably less crime going on during the
World Cup than other times of the year
because people were enjoying it and
watching the soccer wherever they were
all over the country now in Brazil
things are a bit different because
Brazil is an enormous country there are
big parts of the country that have not
received any investment as a result of
the World Cup and Brazil is in a
situation where its growth has been
lagging Brazil can't necessarily look at
the World Cup as something that's going
to stimulate its economy yet just as
South Africa couldn't necessarily look
for a big payoff from the World Cup in
economic terms either but it was
something that
South Africa on the map for a lot of
people and perhaps in the long term they
would see something out of it in terms
of tourism or at least a restoration of
faith that South Africa was a place that
you could visit safely and have a good
time in Brazil though I think that we're
looking at something a little bit
different Brazil to me really needs to
win this World Cup to have any economic
effect because it is a time where the
country has been facing some challenges
expectations for growth have come down
somewhat the broad progress that we saw
during the luiz inacio lula da silva
administration has not necessarily been
continued under his successor Dilma
Rousseff and so if Brazil were to win it
might add confidence add consumer
confidence that could really get this
economy going in the past we've seen a
pattern where countries that host the
World Cup don't necessarily make off
that much better economically but
countries that win the World Cup
do seem to get a little boost over the
next few years so this could be just the
confidence boost that the Brazilian
economy needs however to win it they're
gonna need to make it through some
really tough teams so I don't know if my
money's on Brazil but for the sake of
the Brazilian economy it would be great
if they came through
you